[Musique]
bon
peu
[Musique]
moi c'est clovis et shanda ce guide
patrimoine ludique conférencier à
l'office du tourisme de l'ouest
aussi loin que me souviens quand même
moi était baigné dans le tome m'a fait
des formations pour être guide formation
guy l'amène à moi de savoir la mecque de
la randonnée comme eddy marro trouve au
moins dans les chasseurs alpins avec ma
qualification la bonne grosse qui arrive
à moi au dessus de la tête mais bon à
savoir
revenons dans le pays c'est le début du
touriste et puis bon des années comme ça
en tant qu'accompagnateur en montagne
avec mon petit madame de mafate nous la
gère un gîte gilles du pavillon quatre
ans après donc presque six ans mon l'art
est dans le ciel de cilaos et après d'un
retour aux sources
- un médecin le depuis 2014 l'office du
tourisme de l'ouest qui employa moins
tant que vip patrimoine en fait mais
dans ce patrimoine anna et la partie
montagne et la partie aube et comprendre
aux créoles de son histoire véritable
veillée accroche donc sur les produits
zarlor donc tenu à mettre un gros paquet
de médire et de culture au tour avec une
vraie histoire de la réunion
c'est pas que midi les finis ti fleur
fanée ça sent la banane mais trop
sérieux il vient d'y greffer là-dessus
mais la base la bassée locale donc cette
double mission s'est fait passer le
message que nous nas du patrimoine en
danger
il faut nous sommes d'hab
moi mes pansements maemo les joyeux même
la vie niamke commis trappe de moins ils
recensent a aussi camp nou sava avec
voilà un nom et un bon petit moment pour
partager nous mettre un peu de
sentiments sentiment nous mettre une
pierre dans une visite
s'il vous intéresse le local de toute
façon on lit tout ce climat comprendre
un recensement notre patrimoine mais
maintenant il faut passer l'étape
suivant la restauration ne sera floué
sinon on va avoir des noms comme ben
c'est la 4e minute tout ça ou ou 46 des
quartiers de saint leu où ben on sait
plus pourquoi donc ni aimerait bien que
tout le monde met la main ensemble
pouvoir sauvegarde
en fait ce patrimoine non à ceux commis
gao parler du tourisme
sans parler de notre patrimoine
sauvegardé de restaurer on va faire une
gâterie de manière virtuelle on misait
encore fait aller de manière prise
présentiel encore temps qu'ils vivent